Elle boy was directed by Neil Marshall
and stars David Harbor as Hellboy
himself this is a reboots this is not a
sequel to Hellboy 1 or 2 despite the
fact that Ron Perlman and Guillermo del
Toro we're trying to make a third one
for a long time a lot of people wanted
to see that third film we're getting a
reboot instead and here Hellboy battles
a lot of monsters and demons and an
ancient sorceress hell-bent on revenge
despite being a big fan of the first two
Hellboy films I held no grudge against
these filmmakers and actors for making a
reboot why would I I was of course
curious to see what they could do with
it and having seen it I do wish that del
Toro had just made a third one
eventually with Ron Perlman in it
because I can pretty much guarantee it
would have been a better movie this film
is not as bad as the outrage clickbait
eMachine the Internet has become might
have led you to think but it does
unfortunately feel like a film that's
been botched in the editing room and
changed considerably and if reports are
to be believed it was a difficult set to
work on because there were clashing
creative minds and whenever that happens
on a set especially when some people
feel very prideful
that's a terrible scenario to be and as
a creative person I have a lot of love
for Neil Marshalls films The Descent is
an excellent monster movie filled with
amazing performances in a claustrophobic
setting Dog Soldiers is a highly under
scene and extremely violent werewolf
movie that I've always really liked so
when I heard that he was gonna be doing
Hellboy I was honestly really pumped and
the fact that it's a rated R film -
really lends to a lot of great
possibilities unfortunately similar to
the die hard franchise when the fourth
film was pg-13 and the fifth one was
rated R or the AVP franchise when the
first was pg-13 and Requiem was rated
our making Hellboy rated R has done it
no favors it's just got blood in it
which is cool some of the violence and
action sequences are really awesome
actually there's a great one with three
giants and there's a cool scene in the
middle where he's fighting this creature
that sometimes turns around and walks
like a lobster the action scenes can be
really entertaining and fun and the
violence is very very gory but at the
same time it just feels that the expense
of a story that isn't really there it
doesn't feel like there's a reason for
this reboot to exist
once you see the film from beginning to
end the basis it covers our similar
basis that the first two Hellboy films
did and it doesn't cover them as well as
those films either even some of the
special effects don't look as good as
those earlier films the special effects
here can feel like they're reaching a
little bit just beyond the budget they
have to try to create something amazing
and it's just not quite there yet still
there's some great makeup work
especially David Harbor as Hellboy which
let's talk about him he's terrific
he's my favorite part of this movie by
far still loved Ron Perlman as Hellboy
but David Harbor is really good very
funny
extremely likeable and in the scenes
that require him to really lash out
about his past especially the
relationship with his father played by
ian mcshane he's excellent in those
scenes as well but as far as
performances go he's definitely the
strongest and most of the cast doesn't
come off that great there's a lot of
very wooden and hammy performances here
that just don't fit in but easily my
biggest issue with the film was
unfortunately the script it doesn't
really feel like there is one you can
tell that it's been changed a lot or
shifted around in the editing room or on
sets nothing feels like it flows
characters go from place to place and
they try to make it be as fast-moving as
possible by having every single scene
build to the next one but once you get
to the new scene you almost forget where
you were before because it just felt so
throwaway with tons and tons of needless
exposition and voiceover this movie
definitely talks down to the audience it
makes you feel like you're an idiot
sometimes with the way everything is
explained in explicit detail constantly
as if you needed to know everything and
couldn't just understand it if you saw
it the song choices - for the film felt
out of left field almost like they were
just choosing various songs to lighten
the mood and make you feel like you were
having a good time even though what
you're looking at doesn't seem to
accompany the music you're hearing
they're just trying to create a tone
through good song choices and that
didn't work for me either if the reports
are to be believed I wish that Neil
Marshall was just given complete
creative freedom on this movie and
allowed to make the choices that he
wanted to make because he's a fantastic
filmmaker and I can't wait to see what
else he does David Harbour as good as
Hellboy but this is nowhere near as good
as the previous Hellboy
which I would highly recommend you guys
check out who had never seen him I'm
gonna give Hellboy a c-minus but let me
know what you thought a Hellboy if you
guys did see it cuz I'm curious to see
what other people think and I also want
to give a big thank you to the sponsor
for this video and that is expressvpn if
you guys do a lot of shopping online
like I do which is usually blu-rays
anime game memorabilia and other things
like that that people like me like to
collect then you like your privacy and
you want to make sure that you feel
protected and safe online and expressvpn
is excellent at keeping your information
safe they have the fastest speeds
consistently faster than other VPN
services and they have servers in 94
countries they have apps for every
device Windows iOS Android Mac Linux
router and more it's less than seven
dollars a month with a 30-day money-back
guarantee so find out how you can take
your internet privacy back today and
please visit expressvpn dot-com / Chris
Stockman in the description box below
and you can get three months for free
that's expressvpn dot-com / Chris
Tuchman thank you so much to them for
sponsoring this video and thank you to
you guys for watching as always if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]